what would you be doing differently
right now when it comes to covid it's
actually a good question that that's a
good question from newsmax well one
thing no mandates the mandates are
killing our economy i'm convinced that
when you have supply chain problems you
can't get paper you can't get lumber
they can't build houses they have no
nails they have nothing and i think
to start off with the mandates there is
no evidence at all
that vaccine requirements at businesses
are what is causing supply chain issues
there's just no evidence of that
disaster
and people just aren't working you can't
get people to work because of the
mandate so that would be the first thing
i do because almost a non-factor as you
as many of you know
we have seen that mandates ultimately
lead to you know like at most half of
one or one percent
um staff loss
and there are many
places where it's zero because
everybody's obviously vaccinated any you
know there's just no evidence for what
trump is saying